that makes no sense you would get sick
i'm not saying you wouldn't get sick i'm
just saying that every arrangement is
technically an edible arrangement my
gyno says i ovulate like a champ i drop
eggs hard i i just want a card that will
blow my ugly sister denise's card out of
the water the one with restless leg
syndrome that's not what makes her ugly
sandra that's what makes her legs
restless same rules as last time no
kissing no eye contact i leave as soon
as you're done oh we're not sleeping
together that was just a negotiation
tactic with glenn oh
right
of course get smart
i mean if someone actually cared it
could be super hurtful but it's not tina
who wants to uh say something critical
about me oh oh
oh
baby i've got so many hi i'm dr sidion
i'm the attending on the floor holy crap
it's just feeling very
2003 see your strip mall if that makes
any sense uh that makes perfect sense
you can't help but notice that you're
sweating got any secrets you'd like to
share
no you know some thieves have a tell
like talking with your hand over your
mouth oh
or tricks sandra
you're gonna go with sandra
you are gonna leave your baby at the
mercy of a person whose judgment is so
bad she moved from hawaii to saint louis
yes
i am yeah i just feel more comfortable
with this guy honestly i was never a dr
meyer fan
i didn't want to say anything but during
one of our exams she was accidentally
looking into my butt the whole time i
think she got confused and i felt bad
correcting her look dina i just think
that you're holding in a lot of pent-up
emotion and that it's good to talk about
these things i learned that in couples
therapy oh and that worked out great for
you didn't it tina that didn't work out
for them though actually they're getting
a divorce right now jonah i don't feel
you were uh fair to me wait a minute
this sounds nothing like kelly it's more
like hi everybody i'm kelly no wait no
wait hold on let's do this nice and
accurate how about it okay dina it's not
about doing impressions hey it's me
kelly boy it sure is windy out today
whoa that seems unnecessary jonah you
told me you love me and then you dumped
me so you could have sex with that
pregnant hey these are kelly's
words not we do not negotiate with
terrorists who's the terrorist in this
scenario dina that suit you're wearing
how about a game huh who wants to play
crazy scabies
floor shorts
i guess there is enough of us we could
play hassle the fishmonger but we'd have
to move the couch what we want is for
glenn to be rehired as store manager i
would sooner slit my throat and jeff's
throat before i'd let that happen dina i
don't want to be insulting but are we
sure that idea is not just
pure gay nonsense you don't have the
courage or the intelligence to have
stolen anything then why are you even
talking to me i just wanted you to know
that guess this is what he used to stand
on they just took off the little foot
i'm going to eat a bird now
you know this right here right now this
is my greatest trauma
you know i've never been with a woman
before but
i would switch over for dina well
not happening
i'm uh i'm very straight can you please
just trust me honestly that's gonna be
tough i've always had this weird thing
about people with glasses when i was
younger a nearsighted man bit me you
know it's a long story
i got hep a i'm okay now
did i steal the fruit no was it an act
of civil disobedience that i admire yes
do i know who stole it
no stop interrogating yourself marcus
that was just foreplay all right we're
about to get this thing going i don't
have time to whine about my issues and
frankly i am sick of listening to all
you people whine about yours get off me
move brett
the point is we have a policy for this
so if you see something suspicious
report it don't try to handle it
yourself yeah we all know what the
policy is but what was i supposed to do
just stand there and make brown like
jonah now try smiling but only using
your eyes and ears
yes you are killing it you know i
can fit 40 cherries in my mouth
any more than that and i throw up
okay
do i like fruit yes what's my favorite
fruit
tropical be more specific
mango
now there's something about you i just
don't trust
okay what if someone steals a baby what
then do you want me to just sit there
and watch someone take a baby what if
the baby is wearing a bomb then wouldn't
you want him to steal it i'm trying to
picture a scenario in which somebody
plays oh what if it's baby hitler
a very good question tough is it i think
you got to kill that baby hitler yeah
how would you know that that baby was
gonna grow up to be hitler what if that
baby was gonna grow up to be the exact
opposite of hitler churchill no lance
bass interesting oprah yeah oprah
oprah you got to save that baby
wow
these pictures make me jealous of
everyone i've ever had sex with
officially off cloud9 property now we're
just a couple of civilians
so show me what you got look dina i'm
not i'm not fighting you this is why
because i'm a woman because if you were
really a feminist you'd punch me in the
face i'm very comfortable with nudity
right you must be dena fox hello i'm dr
gillespie i'll be administering the
epidural
damn what is with this place it's like
grey's anatomy in here dennis did i put
you on go backs or did i tell you to
stand around crying about your dead dog
all day this is what you get when you've
got weak joints that's why i have a
dedicated ankle day at the gym young
girl from nazareth you're pregnant with
jesus and you're trying to make a go of
it in a new city but you're lost oh
you're lost in new york
i feel like i'm european
i cannot physically touch you
but i can get very close
can't believe i'm gonna lose my job
i just upgraded all of the trash cans in
my apartment i look like a hot glowing
stanley tucci could you play my music
no problem
[Music]
sorry is this right yeah it's my
favorite song
[Music]
okay
i'm ready uh okay this is gonna sound
crazy but do you remember your first
period because february 4 2003 was a
tuesday unseasonably warm
we're so lucky that darren had this
harness in his trunk huh i'm not letting
my pregnancy slow me down i'm banging my
way through my whole indoor soccer team
and the refs so she just kept the dead
man's wallet and we're all okay with
that finder's keepers
hey so random i was going through some
old security footage with luanne yeah
and you remember how we used to have
those security cameras in the break room
well we came across the time you let all
my birds escape
uh
yeah
remember that remember it was
valentine's day remember i was blaming
myself for it and then when i was at my
lowest you had sex with me knowing that
hours before you were the one that let
them out and you knew the entire time
and yet you said nothing remember that
that was so funny dina i'm so so sorry
hey come on don't even worry about it i
forgive you when you think about it this
whole thing is just funny
hey come with me i want to show you
something
they went up so fast it's like they
wanted to burn
what's that sound
is that air escaping from the sneakers
it almost sounds like they're screaming
i will never forgive you
ever
you